Khloe Kardashian shares a series of
cryptic posts about her mental state
yeah we're getting some really
conflicting messages from Khloe Kay the
34 year old mom took a brief break from
sharing those adorable snaps of true to
share a series of quotes on her inso
story her first message read sending
love to everyone who's trying their best
to heal from things that they don't
discuss then she posted another quote I
wish I had the time for the nervous
breakdown I deserve
Khloe didn't take time to explain the
emotional messages but we have some
thoughts on what she could be alluding
to the first thing that comes to mind is
that she may be healing from that
relationship with Tristan Thompson after
that whole cheating scandal and then the
other thing is she's a new mom so of
course all new moms have this new
responsibility and there are moments
where you kind of want to have a
meltdown yeah it's a lot you know in a
day and age where mental health really
is at the forefront of the conversation
she's saying listen if you have Fame and
money it doesn't matter this happens to
all of us she's just like us yeah I
really like that on the bright side she
has a really strong support system I do
want her to probably take some time away
from social media that seems to have
helped a lot of celebrities lately okay
so despite life's daily struggles Khloe
opened up to et about how being trues
mom has changed her for the better take
a look my favorite part about being a
mom I mean it's so corny but it's just
like no matter how tired you are
whatever you just it's complete bliss
and just when you see your baby and how
happy you just get through it and I was
like okay if I could do anything I could
do this and it's just the best and just
the love that you got you that you also
get to give and receive it's just it's
beautiful I think also motherhood just
puts life into perspective and what's
important to you and and I still think
people who don't have kids there's
definitely there's things that are
important to them too because I felt
that way but I think you just
re-evaluate things like I don't want to
do that tonight and it's okay to say no
so I could spend time with my family and
through it all one thing is for sure her
sisters have her back yes they really do
those Kardashians Chloe Kim and court
recently stopped by watch what happens
live with Andy Cohen and played around
of plead the fifth
it was pretty awesome where the topic
quickly turn to Khloe's man's alleged
infidelity check it out if you were
Chloe would you have stayed with Tristan
oh good good one I speed it up I think I
I don't I think I would really I don't
know that I would we you stuck with Scot
through a lot yeah and I think that
that's her when you have a family like
you do everything you can for your
family and I will say well not I will
say cuz I don't like it so I'm not in
your shoes but from seeing everything
that happened it's so easy and quick to
be like oh my god
I love him leave him right it's so much
harder to stay and have the whole public
think that you're an idiot for staying
like a strength to really not good I got
a hand it's a Courtney's she has a point
and I'm glad that she wasn't a hypocrite
because of the whole Scott Disick thing
Khloe has really been strong throughout
this entire scandal I mean she was
pregnant at the time this is her first
child and this is all happening in the
public eye so we can't really fault her
for how she handled that one thing's for
sure I would love to see Khloe Tristan
and true and some family photos together
and you know I'm sure they're
co-parenting yeah and I gotta give a
round of applause for Khloe she handled
that whole thing so gracefully she never
bashed him in public like really what a
class act
absolutely okay so shortly after her
cryptic stories Khloe went back to her
usual routine sharing those precious
videos of 9 month old true in baby class
[Music]
Chloe is definitely my favorite
Kardashian say hardcore and so if you're
going through it Chloe we love you and
we're sending you all of our love and
care absolutely and of course we're
gonna keep you up today with all the
latest Kardashian news there's a lot so
be sure to subscribe to all things et
until next time I'm at Courtney
underscore tezo now and I'm at Halle
underscore Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]